uh some of the best
investigative journalism is done by
people inside the field
uh comes to mind a guy by the name of
elon musk who
who uh i love the the possibility that
he gets the pulitzer for that interview
but uh he grilled the crap out of vlad
the uh ceo of
uh robin hood i'm not sure
on the clubhouse on clubhouse the other
night yeah i saw you guys in there
i was kept out i wasn't quick enough my
thumbs don't go fast enough so i was and
i wasn't about to sit in the waiting
room have you tried that social network
by the way the clubhouse
i've gone in there a few times and
checked some things out
i'm there i have a few questions about
it that um like if i'm in there
how one can participate or not
participate i
i like being a fly on the wall for those
conversations i've been very curious as
to what's going on in there oh
it's quite i mean i have a lot of
thoughts i've maybe it's useful to
comment
i also have a discord server uh that uh
you know has a few tens of thousands of
people on it and then
they have also a voice chat capability
so there's these get-togethers and i i
was using in
in the spring and summer like actively
uh on those voice discussions and it's
anywhere from 10 to like a thousand
people
all together in voice like you anyone
can speak
anytime right but there's this weird
dynamic that people stay quiet
only one person speaks at a time because
they're all like respectful it's the
community of like
uh like fundamentally respectful people
even though they're all anonymous
so like except like me and a few others
it's all anonymous people so interesting
and it works it's
but the the magical thing to me about
that community was how intimate
voice only communication can be it felt
as intimate as like a
like a small get-together at a home with
close friends
it felt like there's a calmness to it
and you're revealing
things about you know somebody suffering
from depression
or being suicidal so those are the dark
things or being super excited getting a
new girlfriend or
boyfriend like just the the depth of
human experience shared
on voice without video is uh
i was really surprised how intimate that
is for human connection
especially in this time of cover to
replace that so that
so that so just to give you some context
there's something there
there there's definitely something there
one thing that comes to mind is
when like in clubhouse you have your
little icon so they don't actually you
don't see your face moving
i think when people see their own image
it puts them in a state of
self-consciousness that
is eliminated by just having an icon or
an avatar yes right so like
zoom is dreadful because if
i'm not used to talking to people and
seeing a little image of myself staring
back at me in the mirror
and it's just i know there are ways that
you can adjust that but it's
really awful yeah and i think that when
i get on zooms now i say hello and then
i shut down
the video component and then i just talk
in the end i come back on just to show
that
it's still there it's still me but i
think that
voice only is really interesting eddie
chang would be an interesting person to
talk to about this because he
understands so much about how inflection
communicates
emotionality and deeper state but
there's a balance between
i think just like you said this the
privacy
uh somehow uh allows for the intimacy so
like being able to
uh as opposed to put on putting on an
act which i realize we do when we're
visually presenting ourselves right
in remote communication but i think that
there's so few places where people can
actually communicate without the fear of
penalty
yes those that's you know woefully
absent these days and so maybe people
are just relieved to be in a place where
they feel like
i can say what i want or not say
anything and it's okay
and so so clubhouse as you answer your
kind of uh question is
uh there was a big improvement to me
over discord which is
it has tears it has a stage where people
the person that created the room can
invite people up that would like to
speak potentially
have the opportunity to speak and then
there's a bigger audience
that don't get a chance to speak unless
they click raise their hand and they get
called on so there's like a tier system
that allows for there to be a group of
like 5
10 20 30 people talking and a lot larger
amount in the audience which in discord
was the problems that everybody could
talk
and the other thing about clubhouse is
everybody
is strongly encouraged to represent
themselves so you're using your real
name it's not anonymous
and how many people were in that um
gamestop discussion
they currently uh limit rooms to five
thousand so i'm sure
maxed out at five thousand there's a lot
of overflow rooms
this is the cool thing about clubhouse
really big people were on there
all tuned in and having a conversation
having all
from all you know all these different uh
worlds
being able to connect even though
without the niceties of like arranging
the meeting you could just show up and
leave which is very nice
but uh the reason i'm for my lessons
from discord
i'm going to mostly stay away from call
house and
i think we're going there under another
name
right uh uh i'll pretend i know the
actual your actual name on
yeah it's i've learned it's quite
addicting
it's uh it's a time sink it's so the
intimacy of it
is you find yourself wasting quite a bit
of time on there
it pulls you in well it's interesting
they
would in sort of going back to the
podcast or earlier we're talking about
books
or creating a technology one thing
that's absolutely clear is that anything
that's easy to reproduce is probably not
worth
much effort and time yes right i mean
most posts could be easily reproduced
you just repost them
yeah so now there are some original
posts that for which the attribution
goes to the original person it's clear
it came from you
but anything that can be easily
reproduced is doesn't really expand us
very much
as individuals or or as groups and most
of what i see on social media is
stuff that is is purely reproduced yes
right
but i think clubhouse i mean
it could be that some real magic emerges
on there so
in moderation it could be good the magic
is this is another thing that i've
found through kovid that maybe you can
think about
is uh live i used to be
not understand the appeal of live video
or live connection or like in this
clubhouse live events
because clubhouse is technically for the
most part it's not supposed to be
recorded
most people don't record most
conversations it's a one-time live event
and there's a magic to that there is
that's not
captured by a like your podcast or
my podcast produced video that's like
recorded
like packaged up well anything can
happen
it's that anything can happen and those
though that's the kind of thing like
live concerts right i definitely i love
live music
and it's the idea that because you can
always listen to the album actually the
album usually sounds cleaner and better
but it's just this idea that anything
can happen and then you listen to like
the parts i don't know you uh like
costello did something weird uh your dog
did something weird
and then you have to go god damn it you
have to go to the kitchen or something
to get something and then you come back
and it's funny i watch a live video like
that of people
and i'll be there for the whole time
i'll wait for them to go to the kitchen
and come back it's not like i tune out
right and that makes it like a richer
experience for some reason it's weird
well it humanizes it yeah
and i think there is this weird effect
of whether or not it's a podcast
instagram or twitter or anything else
there's
kind of like two people shouting into a
tunnel and then a bunch of people with
ears at the other end of those tunnels
and shouting some things back and
you know that's that's kind of the
format we're in i think
uh i'll check out clubhouse again i've
gone in there a few times during the day
and i was surprised to see how many
people were in there in the middle of
the day
i was like don't aren't these people
supposed to be working exactly but maybe
that is their work well be very careful
about the
um the time sync of it but yeah if you
want to you and i go together we have a
conversation on there
but one of the things you have to figure
out i don't still know
how to do it but how to exit which is
you just do the
isn't there the leave quietly button
yeah no but like when you and i are on
stage having a conversation
um uh like and okay uni is harder
but like uh you really if it's just you
and i
then it's the usual human communication
of like all right i gotta go
like but when it's like four people
you're you don't want to interrupt
everyone announce you're leaving you
just have to i mean
there's a weird dynamic that i haven't
quite figured out
of the etiquette isn't clear the
etiquette is not clear well
the etiquette on different platforms and
how that changes is really interesting
you know how youtube has one etiquette
which is kind of
it's a lot of harshness is tolerated on
youtube video comments
um twitter seems a bit harsher than
instagram
instagram there's kind of it seems to be
a little nice people are really nice
people are really nice on instagram for
the most part
um except for those uh fishing things i
actually know someone who had their
quite sizable account poached by those
copyright they come in with those like
you violated copyright things there's
all sorts of harshness in there
that if you think about it in the real
world i like to think about instagram as
if it was the real world
someone that comes over is basically
saying like hey can i hold your wallet
and go into the bank and i'll get some
money out for you and like
but there's this trust based on the
format it comes in
that it can almost get past your radar
unless you're suspicious
if if you took comments like you know
your
posts get a lot of comments and use it
you just walk past
500 random people on the street and just
listen to what they say
it something like that's ridiculous i
don't have time for that yeah but the
comments somehow take on this importance
and this relevance yes
and you feel we we feel obligated to
give them
value right and so the online
communities
the the rules really are different yeah
um
and they evolve with time which is
fascinating with clubhouse it's a new
social network so it's evolving
and people are figuring out as you go
and the same thing with podcasting
on video and like scientific podcasting
this is the cool thing when i
look at what you've created i'm learning
i'm thinking like hmm that's interesting
to do it this way
because like nobody i have nobody to
copy
not many people to copy you know what i
mean if you threw out an idea i'm not
going to put it out here now because i
i don't want to because knowing you
you'll hold yourself to it no matter
what but when we talked about
um this issue of the challenge of
staying on a particular topic for a
while
i mean you do have some cool stuff
brewing in there oh no no not separate
from this format and i love your
interview format
but um when you told me about that i got
really excited that you might go forward
i'm not gonna tell your audience what it
is it but i will say this it is
super cool i would have never thought
about it it's distinctly different than
what i'm doing or what lex is currently
doing
and if you decide to do that podcast
i will be your first and your number one
fan and i know there are going to be
millions of other
people interested that would be amazing
so
if you decide to go forward with the
idea no um
that would be awesome obviously to say
what it is but now i'm not going to
because
because that's even more interesting
you